on this episode of wheel of science
we're talking aliens
i think i'm pregnant with a little snake
man
this is wheel of science
hey everybody welcome to wheel of
science i'm your host chuck nice and
this is the interactive show that
answers
your questions about the universe i
don't answer your questions about the
universe your very own personal
astrophysicist
dr neil degrasse tyson answers your
questions what's up
neil i'm back home in new york but i
happen to at this moment be
at new york comicon comic-con huh
okay what's the most interesting costume
you've seen
i saw one that looked like a very
convincing alien
and then i realized if that was an
actual alien
no one would notice they landed on the
wrong day
if you're trying to visit humans don't
land on comic-con days
okay because then you'll just blend
right in you got to come
on some other time of just instructions
for the aliens when they come in they go
sage advice sir
sage advice what time is it neil it's
time to spin the wheel
bring it on
[Music]
pedro duran monteleone wants to know
this what can drake's equation
tell us about aliens oh so
drake equation was a way to organize our
ignorance of the universe when we're
trying to figure
out if we can communicate with
intelligent aliens in space
is named after frank drake you first
wrote this equation i think it was the
late 60s might have been early 70s
you start out with the number of stars
in the galaxy
and then you say well what fraction of
those have planets what fraction of
those
that have planets have life what
fraction of those have intelligent life
what fraction those have intelligent
life
with technology what fraction of those
might actually be listening for us at
any given moment you start hacking away
at this number and what's left at the
end
is an estimate for how many
civilizations are out there that you
might want to talk to
and each one of these terms is an
astrophysical question
or you can back it up further and say
what is the rate that stars are being
born
because that will tell you how many
stars you have to search for
so when you put all these terms together
you get an estimate
of how many intelligent civilizations
might be out there
and right now we in my one of my recent
books we actually give the very latest
calculation for this
and there's like billions so we're good
do we really want to talk to billions of
other people yeah i don't know if you or
tell them where you live
that would be bad you don't give
strangers who are your own species
your email address much less sending the
return address to earth out to aliens
across the galaxy who alien stranger
danger alien stranger danger and chuck
you know what the last term in the drake
equation is it's how long
the intelligent civilization might be
around at all
it could be that achieving high
intelligence you now know enough how to
render yourself extinct
so just because you became intelligent
with technology doesn't mean you will
keep that
for all the rest of time maybe
you have an expiration date well
hopefully we don't push that date
up further than it has to be all right
let's move on neil bring it on
[Music]
don rem wants to know this how likely is
the theory
of panspermia for the genesis
of life on earth it's really
good if you look at microbes certain not
all microbes some microbes
are just fine in the high radiation
low temperature dehydrating conditions
of space
and we have them here on earth and you
say why do you have this ability
to resist this that's not a natural
force operating
on your evolutionary history here
but you would need that getting through
the vacuum of space
asteroid impacts kick rocks into
interplanetary space
and they travel and they land on other
planets there's some
number of tonnage of rocks on earth that
actually came from mars
came from other planets in the solar
system so panspermia
is the movement of microbes from one
planet to the other
in the nooks and crannies of the rocks
especially in the crannies
panspermia the earth got banged by a
comet and
impregnated with life it's beautiful
all right judging from that reaction
it's time for a break we'll be back with
more wheel of science right after this
thanks to wix for sponsoring this
episode of wheel of science
did you know that our fastest rockets
take days to reach the moon
but using artificial design intelligence
on wix
will allow you to build a website in a
fraction of that time
yeah like this let's do it with adi
you just answer a few questions and your
site is
almost ready to go go to wix.com
go slash star talk and begin your site
right now
all right welcome back let's get right
to another question neil spin the wheel
bring it on
[Music]
from sanji baskar considering the
environmental conditions of mars
versus europa where are we most likely
to
find aliens my
bet is on your rope bug because that has
an
ocean of liquid water beneath a frozen
layer of ice
maybe a kilometer thick but that ocean
has been liquid for billions of years
billions of years and on
earth's oceans that's where all evidence
points to life having begun so
if you want to find life as we know it
we're going to look for conditions
as we know it and that would be these
oceans in europa
and the only thing left is if you do
find life what do you call it and i
think there's no choice but to call them
europeans
i might have a moment of silence for
that joke
all right it's caption time we put this
picture up on our page
and ask for your best captions and the
winning caption is trey mccoy
it was so big you had to hold it like
this
to this day the best burger i've
ever eaten
i just love it because it has nothing to
do with astrophysics or the cosmos it's
pretty cool
except that burgers are oblate spheroids
and anytime you have objects in the
universe that rotate very quickly
they'll spread out at the equator
and in the limiting case you get a
burger
i'm just saying who knew earth was so
delicious
[Laughter]
hey neil here is a comment from our
wheel of science group
stacy radford vincent says hi
i've been watching wheel of science with
my sixth grade students
and they love it i've encouraged them to
submit questions to me
on the coming topics and then i can send
them
in excellent so chuck that means you
can't be so potty-mouthed from now on
now we have sixth graders watching wheel
of science neil who do you think i
learned this from
those sixth graders
and now it's time for our poll our
question will we
communicate with extraterrestrial
intelligent life in our lifetime
answer the poll right here and neil any
thoughts
maybe but that's not a legitimate answer
is it
i don't know you want a yes or no don't
you yeah
i would say i hope not because if we do
they are way smarter and more
technologically able than we are
and anytime that's happened on earth it
hasn't voted well
for the one who did not have the
technology hmm so what you're saying is
you'd rather us communicate with dumb
aliens
yes because otherwise they will just
make us their pets
well that's our show and it was a good
one as always we have to say thank you
to the one the only dr neil degrasse
tyson thanks neil thank you chuck and as
always i bid you
to keep looking up
can i stop looking up now
hello earthlings it is time to do what
you humans do best
do things on the internet that's right
and you can do it with total design
freedom wix is the best place to make
your personal or professional website
it does everything you can possibly want
it to do wix has industry leading seo
tools to help you rise above the rest
also wix automatically creates mobile
optimized versions of your site
so it will look spectacular on any
device
and with advanced design features like
animated background and scrolling
effects
it'll look like you have decades of web
design
experience we could actually make your
background a video
head over to which dot com slash go
slash star talk
and start designing your site today
that's wix.com slash go slash start talk
and be the design star that you know you
are wow already
look at that hey thanks for watching
we'll see you next time on will
of science you can look down
[Music]
you